hi everyone welcome to this pow shell
tutorial by simply learn where we will
discuss some key points of Powell like
what is Powers shell how does poell work
why is poell used and some advantages of
Pell at the end we will perform some
important commands of poell in the demo
part so before jumping to what pow shell
is if you are an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certification from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading expert to your credibility then
search no more simply launch
post-graduate program in cyber security
from MIT University in collaboration
with EC Council should be a right choice
this postgraduate program in cyber
security is designed to equip with the
skills required to become an expert in
the rapidly growing field of cyber
security this cyber Security Programs
aims to help stay a breast of all the
latest Trend in the cyber security as
well designed to accommodate a diverse
range of Learners this course require
just a bachelor degree with a 50%
average no prior programming experience
and one plus year of experience preer so
for more details use the link in the
description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
Powell Powell is an open source command
line tool that leverages microsoft.net
technology it serves as both a shell and
a scripting language allowing automation
of task and configuration for developers
it admins and developed professionals
the command line interface provides
efficient control over the computer
enabling easy reproduction of commands
and minimizing errors Powershell
scripting language conveys instructions
from one software to another unlike
compil languages like Ruby or python it
interprets commands line by line
enhancing parent software functionality
for automation data extraction and
configuration management so moving
forward let's see how does Powershell
work power shell rooted in The NET
Framework operates more like a
programming language than a traditional
command Lang line tool it revolves
around object treating everything as an
object with Properties or methods so
these objects seamlessly flow through
the program as input or output
manipulated by four types of commands
cmdl command Le power shell function and
the third one is Powershell script and
the fourth one is executable commands so
moving forward let's see why is
powerwell used so built on the Net
Framework Powershell functions a keen to
a programming language rather than than
a typical command line tool It Centers
on objects viewing everything as an
object with Properties or methods these
object fluidly move through the program
as input or output subject to
manipulation by four type of commands so
some key points why powerwell used are
the first one is enabling task
automation firstly po shell excels in
task automation with devops as a
scripting language it primarily employed
for automation across various use cases
its unique format system make it prefer
choice for Automation and its
extensively with functions classes CMD
LS and modules enhance its capabilities
the second one is driving data
accessibility powershell's popularity is
also attributed to its role in data
accessibility primarily used in
administrative task it provides it admin
seamless access to diverse data stores
with large computer networks including
file system and Registries the third one
is managing infrastructure as a code a
third reason is a Powers Shield use of
the desired State configuration DSC
framework allowing users to manage
company infrastructure through
configuration as code managers or it
admins develop Powershell skills to push
or pull configuration models for
seamless compossibility these skills are
essential for enforcing settings
achievement repeatable deployments and
creating declarative configuration the
fourth one is facilitating remote
commands lastly Powershell broad
acceptance and versatility stem from its
capability to remote command
facilitation remote work is highly
sought after and tools enabling it gains
immense popularity pow shell enables
administrators to execute remote
operation on multiple system facilit by
Windows management instrument and the Ws
management protocol and at the last we
will discuss some advantages of
Powershell now let's move forward and
see some advantages of Powershell the
first one is extensible format system
Powershell simpli user input formatting
and output customization through three
flexible formatting methods allowing
easy manipulation for any desired
setting the second one is built-in data
formats po shell supports data formats
like CSV Json and XML enabling storage
transfer and readability for both humans
and machine CSV and inbuilt format
stores table data and plain data as well
with each file separated by the comma
the third one is easy automation aell
employs a simple single function command
Le for task implementation which can be
used independently or combined for
complex task it includes over 90 basic
command lets and developers can create
and share custom command Le facilitating
easy automation for repetitive task the
fourth one we have self-service
deployment poell empowers each exchange
team to independently create their
command LS offering a significant
Advantage with a self-service model that
allow developers to manage their feature
concurrently with their development the
last one we have consistent API Windows
apis like Windows management
instrumentation and component object
model are recognized for their
unlikeness and incompleteness leading to
inefficiency in handling request to and
from the browser so moving forward let's
jump into our demo part so hi guys
welcome to this demo part of power shell
tutorial so we will be implementing some
basic commands like get content test
connection get help get date and start
sleeps or write host some these type of
commment so we will Implement one by one
and we will see the output of the
particular okay so this is our
Powershell IC screen Windows Powershell
IC screen so we will Implement commands
one by one and the output will use okay
so our first command is PS version table
so we will write
dollar
PS version
table right so here this button is there
so you can run script here so as you can
see okay let me make it big yes so as
you can see a version table right so
where is the addition desktop so these
are the table so what is version table
right so to check the version of
Powershell uh you are using on Windows
10 or 11 or open open a Powershell
windows and enter this PS version table
into the prompt so the current
Powershell version will be displayed
next to the PS version so finding your
Powershell version helps you know what
Powershell uh features have access to
right so moving forward we will
Implement our second command called
location so I will remove this and I
will enter location right so first let's
run it so
path where your Powershell I is
installed so it will show that path
right so my current path is this desktop
so the current working location is the
default location to which commands
points right in other words this is the
location that Powershell uses if you
don't Supply an explicit path to the
item or the location that is affected by
the command right let's move forward and
see our third command which is known as
alas right so let's run this as you can
see here the all the alas G right for
each object these these are all the
commands different different commands of
particular this power right so an alas
is an alternate name for the command L
cmdl function or executable file you can
say so including scripts the Powershell
includes a set of buil-in function built
in alas you can can say so you can add
your own alas or function to the current
session and you can use your Powershell
profile into your Powershell profile
okay so let's move forward to the
fourth uh this function which is known
as
di right so if I will run it so di so it
will tell you the directory of your
particular this file name right okay so
the DI command in this Windows command
shell shows the targeted location of a
file system Junction point so in
Powershell this information is
available uh from the target property of
the file system so object can return by
the get children and is displayed in the
default output right so moving
forward let's see our next
command so here you can like we used to
do in different different languages like
hello we will print hello world so how
we can print here so here we can write
write
post here you can add your text hi
everyone okay just you have to run it so
here okay this is right dash host so yes
as you can see hi everyone is printing
okay and you can
print basic programming word hello
world right let so as you can see here
hello world is print so right host is a
wrapper for right information this
allows you to use right host to emit
output to the information stream this
enables the capture of uh suppression of
data written using right host while
preserving the PPS compatibility right
so moving forward let's create one file
name here I will create one
file file text document I will name it
simply learn. dxt okay so this is our
file simply learn. txt let me make it
small yeah so this is our file so here I
will add text hi
everyone how are
you okay so I will save it and I will so
how you can get this content okay okay
so there is one command known as get
content so get content in Powershell is
used to read the content from the
particular file text file okay so all
the programs uh from the the desired
location or the specified location so
this function this get content function
gets the content of the file one at the
time and return it's a collection of
objects so how we can do it so we have
to write it
here
C
content and the file name
simply simply learn.
dxt okay oh to write I can write it here
as well but I will like to write
here better
visual
okay okay maybe spelling mistake is
there spelling mistake is there
simply simply learn doxt so as you can
see we got the content hi everyone how
are you and if you will check here the
data is return
okay so this is how you can get content
from the particular file moving forward
let's uh move to the our next command
which is out file or if you want to
append on a particular file like simply
learn. text if you want to write
something else like I'm good how are you
like this any text so how we can do so
we can write
here uh like I'm
good what
about
you right then here I can write
out file and
simply simply
le. dxt your file name then
append right so using the outfile
command so it will send output to a file
particular file so it implicitly uses
Powershell formatting system to write to
the file so the file received the same
display representation as a terminal
okay so here I will run it okay if we
will check check see as you can see here
it is written I am good what about you
okay we have appended particular text
into the simply learn text file right
what if I want to add text into a
different you know documentation so for
that you have to nothing you have to do
you have to just change the file name so
here I will write simply instead of
Simply l
okay and I will run
it
right
so
here file is created and it is written
here I am good but about you right this
is how you can create a different file
and you can add your text and or you can
say append your text right moving
forward uh we will see some geted fun
so for that I will write here simply I
have to write
get dat right enter it let's run it okay
so as you can see today is 11 December
2023 the time is this the minute is this
and the settings are this right so the
get date command gets a date time object
that represent the current date or a
date that you specify okay so get date
use format the date and time in a
several net and the Unix formats so you
can use get dat to generate a date or
time correct string and then send the
string to the other command or program
okay so we will see the start sleep
function so the start sleep command
suspends the activity in a script or a
session for the specified period of time
like 5 Seconds 10 seconds or minutes you
can say and you can use it for many
tasks such as waiting for an operation
to complete or pausing before repeating
an operation
so how it will work I will write
see
write
poost right
host
sleeping for five
seconds right and I
want background
color color should be
black
and foreground color should
be C lettick right and here I will write
start
see
seconds
five okay let's run it so watch it here
carefully okay in the
terminal it is printed but one 2 3 4 5 5
seconds after 5 Seconds this particular
thing you know came so as you as I told
you so you can use such as a waiting for
an operation to complete so this is the
operation to complete okay sleeping for
5 seconds right and or pausing before or
repeating for a nomination so this is
how you can use this start sleep okay
you can add 10 seconds you can add two
seconds if I will add two seconds okay
let's that 2 second see it will pause
for the 2 second one two that's it and
it came
right so moving forward let's see get
command
okay
get
command Okay I want
to get the
command
right so as you can see all the command
is starting from right which has the
right word it came right so this get
command uh gets all the commands that
are listed on the computer okay with
right you can use any particular sort of
word including command alas function
filter scripts and application get
commands get the commands from Parell
modules and those imported from the
other sessions as as well so this is
done so moving next we will see get
dis get this okay it's running wait so
get get dis will get your the serial
number of the
dis you know the health and the
operation station and the total size of
the particular you know dis installed
into your system okay so the get dis
command gets one or more dis object
visible to the operating system or
optionally a filter
list
okay what I can
do
select
on
select select
all as you can see
here it is telling all the things about
my disk right
uh size of the disk
512 and
this manual
Factor uh everything about the disk okay
so moving
forward we will see our next
command. say testt connection test
connection okay so here I will write
test
connection computer name
then I will write here
www.
google.com right and I will run it so as
you can see the IP came okay and the
sources came the destination is G all
the bites and the typ so the test
connection command sends internet
control message protocol icmp Echo
request package or ping to one of the
more report computers and return the
echo message packages right so you can
use this command to determine whether a
particular computer can be contacted
across an IP network or
not okay so moving forward to our last
command which is
get
help
content
online right so let's wait so in this
this page will come it will go to the
online to the Microsoft and it will come
with the get command okay get content
all the content online right we can't
use test connection because every test
connection is not online so I use this
get content online okay it will open
this Microsoft page and it will show you
all the contents related to
potion right so yes so we are done with
the our basic commands
so here we have come to end of this
video if you love anything about this
video please do like share and subscribe
if you have any question regarding
Powershell please comment down below our
team of expert will help you as soon as
possible thank you and keep learning
with simply staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here